-Can I ask you to tell the story
that you told about
"Bon Appetit" magazine?
-This is about you.
I'm here to talk about you.
-So the "Bon Appetit" magazine
is in my new special,
"The Old Man and the Pool."
No, it's --
can you tell that story
or you don't want to
tell that story?
-Sure, I can tell it.
I mean, it's a long story.
We'll have to probably
cut it out of the show.
I don't know, but...
I was just telling this
story that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love this story. If they
cut it out, they cut it out.
-My mom was
a very, very funny person,
and always, she would call me up
and she would say something
to either annoy me
or something like that.
And I'd go, "All right, Mom,
I can't take it anymore.
I've got to hang up."
She'd be like, "Don't hang up.
Wait, wait. One more thing."
So I called her once,
I said, "Hey, Mom,"
I go,
"'Bon Appetit' magazine called.
For Mother's Day,
they're doing a special issue
and they want to know if you
have any recipes maybe."
She goes, "Oh, my God.
'Bon Appetit' magazine.
Oh, my --
I'm going to be
in 'Bon Appetit' magazine?
Oh, my God. I don't know
what I'm going to do.
Maybe my shrimp recipe?"
I go, "Whatever."
I go, "Think about it.
Call me tomorrow
and let me know."
And she said, "Okay."
So I get the phone call
the next day and she goes,
"I got the recipe
that I'm going to give.
It's my cheesecake recipe."
I go, "Okay, great, I love it.
Well, can you send it over?"
She's like, "Yeah,
Daddy's going to type it,
because you know, he knows
how to use the computer."
So my Dad,
"I'll type the thing."
So he types out the thing,
makes a big deal.
-That's a really funny
impersonation of your dad.
-He loves it. He loves it.
-[ Groans ]
Cruel. Cruel.
-So he emails it to me,
and so I get the thing,
and so I give it
to 'Bon Appetit' magazine,
emailed to them.
They go,
"Alright, Jimmy, thank you.
Thank your mom so much."
You know, we have to
make this recipe
to make sure it's good.
Sure. Of course.
Do whatever you guys got to do.
So they call back the next day
and they go,
"We made your mom's recipe
and it's fantastic.
It's really good."
[ Crowd awws ]
I go,
"Okay, cool, I love it."
"Can you ask her,
is there a story behind it?
You know, did she get it
from Grandma or somebody?"
Is there
something behind this?"
I go, "Absolutely."
So I call my mom.
She goes, "Hello?"
I go, "Bon Appetit' loves it."
She's like, "Oh, my God.
I'm going to be
in 'Bon Appetit.'"
I go, "They want to know,
is there a story behind it?"
Is it Grandma's?
What's the story
behind the recipe?"
She goes,
"Hold on a second."
And she puts the phone
on the chair
and I can hear her
scuffling over to the thing,
and I hear she opens up
the cupboard,
and then I hear paper, like --
And she goes, "Yeah.
I got it from
'Bon Appetit' magazine."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Great story.
-"I'm hanging up."
"I'm hanging up the phone.
I've had enough."